I'd like to know more about low-ired and its relationship to cancer.
I've been taking OptiFerrancy every other day for about six or eight weeks.
As I was muzzle tested for it, I just had a colonoscopy and all was okay there, so no
bleeding for anything.
I just had labs done again, and my ferritin was 54.
August, it was 16.
So let's stop there a second and discuss ferritin.
So ferritin is the primary storage form of iron in the body, it's called iron is stored.
If you have decreased levels of ferritin, it's commonly associated with iron deficiency,
but there's other tests that you have to compare it to if you're going to diagnose
iron deficiency, not solely just ferritin.
Increased levels can be associated with iron overload, but increased levels are really
a marker of inflammation, and so people that have really high ferritin levels, it means
they have a lot of inflammation, a lot of inflammation in their blood, increases their
risk of cardiovascular disease, they have a lot of oxidative stress going on.
Again, low levels can be iron deficiency, andemia can actually be vitamin C, insufficiency,
let's say if a person was fasting for a long period of time.
And I think you mentioned here about your thyroid can also be tied to hypo thyroid issues.
So ferritin was 16 in August, and you got up to 54, after taking iron supplementation,
which would suggest that, if there's a correlation there, the supplementation of iron, increased
ferritin, which would suggest that it was really the low ferritin was from iron deficiency,
anemia.
But iron went from 59 to 42, so a little discussion on iron, so serum levels on iron reflect
what is bound to serum proteins.
So you have different proteins in your blood, transfer it is a protein in your blood that
folds iron.
Serial iron levels will fall when you have depletion of iron stores, if you have, if you start
to develop anemia, iron deficiency, anemia that we're talking about.
So when a person has low iron, then you're starting to think about iron deficiency, anemia.
But also you could have, also the other thing you should look at, when you have low iron,
you have low red blood cells, and you have other signs of anemia, like a decreased MCH, a decreased
MCV, a decreased MCHC, typically a decreased ferritin that I already discussed, decreased
percent transfer in saturated, decreased hemoglobin, decreased hematocrit, and a increased
red cell with the R&W, then we're sure you have iron deficiency, anemia.
So there's different types of anemia that can tie to this.
But the other thing you want to look at is am I losing iron somehow by bleeding.
So it's not uncommon if you're still having your period that you could be losing iron
through your period.
You already made mention that you did a colonoscopy and there wasn't any bleeding involved.
While the colonoscopy only goes up through your colon, you have 25 feet of small intestine
and then you have your stomach also that you could be losing blood at two.
So you want to look at am I losing blood somewhere?
Typically if you have a bleeding ulcer, if it's bad enough, you'll have a darker stool,
even a black, tarry stool if you have a really bad bleeding ulcer.
Typically you also have pain from it, but you can have just a mild bleeding ulcer in your
losing blood that way too.
The other thing you're concerned with with cancer in iron is that cancer, if cancer is growing
in a person, anemia is common because cancer tends to gobble up iron.
So that's the relationship that cancer has with iron.
So if your red blood cell count is steady at four, still with a normal range, your iron went
from 59 to 42, so that went down by total iron-biting capacity stayed at 370 and technically
370 is too high.
So total iron-biting capacity is an approximation of the serum transferant level, so remember
I said serum transferant was a protein in the serum that binds iron.
It carries iron around in the blood.
So elevated levels of total iron-biting capacity are associated with iron deficiency anemia
and I think the lab levels or the ranges, the optimal range of total iron-biting capacity,
I think with both labs it's about 250 to 430 or something like that, but really the functional
range is like 250 to 350, so you would be elevated above the functional range there, which ties
in to the low iron, which ties into the iron deficiency.
So I would number one, you're trying to investigate, why do I have iron deficiency, can it be because
of low thyroid possibly?
Can it be because of possible bleed somewhere, still possibly?
You can do a simple occult blood test where you put a little sphere of feces on this little
card thing, you can buy these occult blood tests, different places have to look up, we haven't
used those for years, but you can test that, I will test for what's called occult blood,
which means like hidden blood in your feces, which is kind of an investigation of am I losing
blood through my digestive tract somewhere, so you could have a hidden slow bleed stomach ulcer
or dewandal ulcer that is not causing enough blood loss that's causing black tarystools,
but you still could have enough blood loss to have a slight edemia because you would be in
that category of a slight edemia, you don't have all these other factors that I mentioned
of edemia, but you do have low iron and elevated above functional range of total iron binding
capacity, so by definition you're at the early stages of edemia or coming out of edemia,
so hopefully it's getting better, so we want the total iron binding capacity to drop down
and we want your iron levels to go up and your ferritin levels could stay pretty much where
they're at right there, and we want that to go up, on reading, continuing your question,
reading on the internet, I saw that low thyroid could be responsible for low iron by TSH improved
from 7 to 2.3 because I've been taking the glandular that you suggested, I don't know if I should
be concerned, that my low iron is some kind of cancer indicator, I've tend to run a little
low in my life, but not usually out of range, so can have a kid, let's say I could be feeling
great, I have no other signs of cancer coming back, but I look at my CBC and completely metabolic
panel and I've seen early stages of edemia, is that a sign of the cancer coming back, that's
your question, some kind of cancer indicator, you want to compare that with past tests,
so past tests, past CBCs have shown even a worsened levels of edemia, and this is still showing
slight edemia, but it's not gone, it's not gotten a lot worse, and I would say no, it's not
an indicator of cancer growing, but I would say something you do want to keep an eye on, this
is why doing these deep dives into simple blood tests like CBC could give you a lot of clues that
something is going on, it's important to do, I just spoke to somebody the other day who had a blood
test done several months ago, it showed some clues of metastasis that their ecologists never even,
never even actually went over the blood test at all, so you miss the clues if you don't dig into it,
so digging into this is basically my first clue would be iron deficiency edemia,
possible internal bleeding that would be causing iron deficiency edemia, and then the other thing
that I did it really talk about is the other possibility of hypochlorhydria, so hypochlorhydria,
you mentioned hypochlorhydride, which can tie to it, but mainly hypochlorhydride ties to ferritin,
not so much iron, but the other thing that could cause low iron and elevated total iron binding
capacity is another thing which is hypochlorhydria, so what do you have a decreased hydrochloric acid in
your stomach, that can also tie, that can also be a cause of low serum iron, so you need adequate
levels of stomach acid to absorb iron, so a person can be deficient in iron, so they basically have
a deficiency in iron, in order for iron to be used by hypochlorhydride and be brought to the cells,
because they have a decreased hydrochloric acid in their stomach, they're not able to absorb it,
now typically you want to look at the complete metabolic panel and look at total globulin,
because many times you'll have an increased total globulin with hypochlorhydria as well,
so if you also have an increase in your blood urea nitrogen,
then it's that you probably for sure have hypochlorhydria, now that's probably the easiest fix
of all, because that's taking HCl or apple cider vinegar with your food and taking more with larger
meals, so and I will say that every dysfunction of the human body in all of mankind throughout
the entire world, hypochlorhydria is probably the most common thing that exists that's known to
them, especially in a world that is eats a western diet, because everything that we eat,
food, attitudes, colorate, preservatives, chemicals, everything we eat affects our stomach,
vital cells, ability to make hydrochloric acid, so hopefully that helps.